foreign
this is the true story of the frontier
of the Wild West
and the founding of America
Frontier is a very loaded word
it was a dividing line between
civilization and savagery
which was imagined to be indigenous
people
a violent tale of European colonists
pushing ever deeper
into an unexplored Wilderness the West
has long figured in the American
imagination as the Land of Hope and
promise of an indigenous people it
exploited and conquered by treaty or by
force God gave it to the Indians first
so it'll always be a hard land it'll
always be our country in a chaotic War
for freedom
annikling The Carving up of a continent
birth of Lawless cattle towns
the ruthless rise of the railroad
[Music]
feverish breed of the gold rush
witness the brutal reality
How the West Was Won
the Bonafide history of life
on the frontier
[Music]
the whole story is about opportunity
opportunity for land
opportunity to make a new life
[Music]
Americans always looking to the next
Horizon from you know Columbus and the
Vikings
the West Was Always what was considered
the frontier the front end of modernity
in the 19th century American history
a land where anything was possible
Frontier made America different perhaps
more individualistic more
more the people who are stating that a
frontier exists do so because they want
to distinguish themselves from the
people that they see on the other side
of the boundary and that can be
politicized even weaponized the scene
was really set for a showdown between
these American settlers who claimed
access to that land and the native
people who had long since lived there
it changed everything
native people become known as The
Vanishing race
you can't survive if you want to or you
can just lay down and die it's only once
people understand the cost of these
territorial acquisitions
that will be able to
fairly judge the past
Amerigo Vespucci was the first European
to suggest the landmass stumbled upon by
Christopher Columbus might be a
continent in its own right
a map drawn up in 1507 marked South this
bold Discovery borrowing a derivative of
the Explorer's name
America
the British began arriving sort of in
trickles in the early 17th century
they set up colonies in Virginia and
then what's today in Massachusetts but
they basically hugged the Eastern
Seaboard for decades it was very
difficult for them to make inroads
because the native people in what would
become New England and in Virginia were
powerful they were numerous and they
weren't inclined to just give their land
away did these newly arrived English
settlers
there were 13 colonies on the mainland
of North America
[Music]
all of which were controlled by the
British
these were independent political
entities that were governed by the crown
when you look at how the land
encompassed by The Colony is defined
most of them don't have Western
boundaries written into their Charters
so the idea is that the colony could
expand Westward indefinitely
the 13 colonies wanted to expand
actually begin to go into areas that
they weren't supposed to
and so the British government introduced
what is known as the Proclamation line
of 1763
and in doing that it really established
a line across the crest of the
Appalachian Mountains
a temporary boundary is established by
the British
separating the colonists from Native
American lands
and the colonists were supposed to stay
east of that next to the Atlantic
seaboard
this didn't however prevent a swell of
white settlers from breaching the
Proclamation line
encroaching on native land seeking to
harness its natural resources
what you had was fur Trappers fur
Traders people who could make a living
hunting wanted to live out in the
wilderness away from society or whatever
Mountain Men
tough rugged figures undaunted by the
countless dangers of this hostile
wilderness
built peaceful relationships with local
tribes
setting up vital trade routes which
would be used for decades to come
majority of mountain men would form
alliances with a tribe on Whose land he
was he was trapping Furs and they they
created interim relationships that way
but it was it was an isolated way of
life American Hunters fed Europe's
insatiable desire for fur
in particular
hats fashioned from beaver pelts
although practically any wild creature
with a hide could be killed skinned
[Music]
and sold for a handsome profit and so
the fur trade industry flourished and
the market for it was primarily Europe
and Asia people would buy fur coats fur
hats lined boots and gloves with fur and
it was extremely profitable
American traders and Trappers were
engaged in Cutthroat competition with
one another it was sort of a tragedy of
Commons effect what they did to the fur
trade because of course each individual
Trader and Trapper wanted to secure as
many beaver pelts as he possibly could
knowing that those pelts that he didn't
secure his rival would so over time they
drastically drove down the population of
beavers in North America in this attempt
to claim more than their rivals
however
alongside Traders came homesteaders
willing to push further into native
lands
harboring dreams of permanently settling
down and building communities
despite the official guidance of the
British and this is one of the reasons
why the American colonialists rebelled
against the British because they wanted
to be able to continue to take over the
land and the resources of native peoples
and that becomes one of the main
controversial points
with the British crown
[Music]
you always talk about it as taxes and
tea and everything else but my argument
would be that it's actually a lot about
its access to indigenous land
is what triggers the American Revolution
the first shots of the war of American
independence are fired in April 1775.
under the command of George Washington a
ragtag militia clashes against the
military might of the British Empire
indigenous people realize that the new
United States would be a great danger
for them
and so they're very dedicated to trying
to stop it Native Americans fight side
by side with the British in a Bloody War
which rages on for eight long years
facing a crushing defeat King George's
Representatives finally sign a peace
treaty the 13 colonies of Great Britain
are now
the United States of America
Independence has been won
but none for all
[Music]
the 13 United States of America are
enshrined in law
as an independent Sovereign Nation
the leaders of this new nation set their
sights on the American West it was 13
colonies that became 13 states some of
those States laid claim to this vast
domain far beyond the Appalachian
Mountains
and the states gradually had to give up
claim to this land in order to carve out
new States from that by and
the United States was looking for ways
to sort of distance itself from the
colonial precedent that Britain had set
the United States wanted to expand
Westward but it didn't want to do so
with colonies it wanted to do so by
creating additional co-equal States so
what Congress decided to let happen is
any time a federally designated
territory reached the population
threshold of residents it could apply
for Statehood and once it earned
statehood it would come into the Union
as a co-equal member with all the rights
that the other 13 original states had
these rights allowed each new state a
vote on any law passed through Congress
[Music]
all states were entitled to two senators
as well as voting members of the U.S
House of Representatives
the way that United States history is
typically told is from the point of view
of the 13 colonies and then eventually
they form this independence movement
that results in the nascent United
States it's actually a nation that's
dedicated in many ways to the project of
western expansion
and George Washington besides being the
general for the Continental Army is also
a very significant land Speculator in
Western lands so the leadership down to
lower level people are all very
interested in western expansion
the revolution itself resulted in a
major unresolved controversy over the
American West overlands West of the
Appalachian Mountains but in the peace
treaty when Britain surrendered in 1783
to the newly created United States they
seeded native land whether they had any
right to do so was an open question
[Music]
I think we always want to be careful
though whether we're talking about
Frontiers or Borderlands or borders for
that matter not to draw them prematurely
if you look at almost any U.S history
textbook for example
you'll see oftentimes maps to trace out
the expansion of the United States
Frontier or place borders sometimes
where European treaty makers place them
as opposed to really paying attention to
the reality on the ground
so in one sense we can have two maps
a map of India North America in 1776 at
the time of the Declaration of
Independence
would show North America divided among
Spanish America British America French
America and then after the American
Revolution British America becomes the
United States
part of French America is now British
America up in Canada
and we still have Spanish America in the
southwestern part of the United States
and that's one map that that sort of we
often use it's as I said a map that
erases the reality on the ground which
is that most of that territory are
Indian countries and that a realistic
map would show most of the continent
being occupied by Indian peoples with
maybe little dots of colonial settlement
amongst oceans of different Indian
nations different Indian peoples
Maps can reveal a great deal
but they can also distort and erase a
whole lot of history too
one of the big political questions of
that era is you know who would exercise
jurisdiction over which parts of North
America it wasn't entirely clear at the
time
partly because population density wasn't
that great
so you didn't have Imperial Powers
really coming into regular contact and
conflict with one another by and large
these Empires were lines on a map they
laid claim to vast amounts of territory
but that territory was really dominated
and inhabited by native people
the scene was really set for a showdown
between these American settlers in the
newly created United States who claimed
access to that land and the native
people who had long since lived there
when I gather with it a lot of the
people that came on the on those boats
over here
or the bottom of the barrel from those
countries you know there were the
thieves in the Outlaws and whatever you
want to say and we were here waiting for
them with good arms and saying come on
we're going to share our food and teach
you how to plant teach you how to make
food whatever
and then they were taken advantage of
[Music]
North America before
Europeans arrived was culturally very
diverse
it was linguistically very complex it
involved a degree of environmental
manipulation
whether it's controlled Burns or whether
it's agriculture whether it's irrigation
that I think is often forgotten about
one of the dangers of the notion of the
frontier is the idea that everything was
very static on the indigenous side and
the U.S side is sort of where all the
dynamism is but it's really important to
understand is that everything is moving
really really quickly and there's a lot
of change that's going on on the
indigenous side as well
you have the horse spread out onto the
Great Plains in the late 18th century as
well
so a lot of indigenous communities there
begin to incorporate the course into
their way of life and this becomes a
really transformative new technology as
it were for them
[Music]
enabling their populations to rise
enabling themselves Buffalo and away and
scale that they'd never been able to
before
natives swap animal hides
beads food and knowledge
for iron tools newly introduced by the
colonists
outposts are established and with them
local economies
the United States
was growing
serious change was afoot
Not only was it pushed by these powerful
political Beasts of the East Coast
but by Napoleon Bonaparte
[Music]
the Frenchman had once dreamed of
creating a new world Empire stretching
from the Caribbean Into the Heart of
North America
but now the military Mastermind was
reassessing his Ambitions following his
latest humiliating defeat in Haiti
the history of the American West really
begins with a slave rebellion in the
Caribbean on what was then the French
sugar colony of San domingue and what
became the independent Black Republic of
Haiti
a group of enslaved people there led a
rebellion led by Tucson Overture
overthrew their French slave holders and
created a black Republic by 1804.
so once Napoleon lost Haiti he sort of
gave up the the whole idea of a new
world Empire and so he actually sold a
massive stretch of land in North America
Napoleon looked at Louisiana
and didn't think it was worth governing
so he was anxious to get rid of it and
found a willing purchaser in Thomas
Jefferson
there are certain presidents especially
in this time period that we're talking
about that kind of create their
political parties and Thomas Jefferson
pretty much created his political party
he was the first politician elected to
that party and around him coalesced all
of these ideas that came to be known as
the Jeffersonian Republicans
foreign so when Thomas Jefferson becomes
president he's really a new voice and a
new idea for the United States
Jefferson had a new vision for America
that was very agrarian and it was also
very in favor of territorial expansion
he lives on a farm a plantation worked
by many many slaves and he firmly
believes that the only really ethical
way of living is to work the land either
work the land yourself or enslave people
and force them to work it for you so
he's he's suspicious of cities
suspicious of urban dwellers Jefferson
said that cities were sores on the body
politic so his idea of what the United
States should be made up of is
individual farmers and their families
this is this idea about how the
government will stay virtuous is that
every man will own his own land and
every man will work his land with his
family along his side that's what
freedom to Jefferson means what that
means in terms of the policies that he's
going to support he is in favor of
adding more land to the United States so
that you can get all of those men their
farms for their families
in order to expand his territory
president Thomas Jefferson is a mint of
France to barter for control of New
Orleans and West Florida
but Napoleon needed money to wage his
next military campaign
he presented the Americans with an
incredible opportunity for 15 million
dollars he would grant them the rights
to a colossal body of land
Louisiana Jefferson himself was probably
gobsmacked by that offer it was just too
good to pass up it doubled the size of
the United States overnight
with the stroke of a pen
France turns over retro seeds an
enormous colony to the United States
at the time that was a good chunk of
change for the United States that was
still in its infancy and didn't have the
the resources to sort of deal on a stage
with Imperial powers like France but the
Louisiana Purchase also unlocked this
incredible money-making opportunity for
the federal government it was really
through the sale of federal lands lands
in the Louisiana Purchase that the U.S
government was financed for years and
years to come
[Music]
the Louisiana Purchase started where the
Mississippi River spills into the Gulf
Coast and it went all the way west of
the Mississippi River somewhere up there
nobody was exactly sure where it ended
the United States had just acquired 828
000 square miles
of Uncharted Terrain
land previously owned by France
but barely governed by Napoleon's forces
in truth much of the vast area
was already inhabited
by native people
what's left out and what the maps that
we use tend to leave out is again the
United States made a deal with France to
acquire a certain kind of control a
certain kind of right but that right has
yet meant very little on the ground in
the ground remained almost entirely
Indian countries and yet our Maps tend
to sort of erase all those Indian
boundaries and borders and pretend that
the United States had doubled its size
now the eventual cost of actually taking
control over all that territory is
considerably more once you start
factoring in the cost of
either purchasing or coercing or
conquering uh the Indian peoples in
those territories to take effective
controls of the territory
so the one thing that was standing in
the way of Jefferson's imagined Empire
and the one thing that was standing in
the way of the United States really
exerting control over this Louisiana
Purchase is of course native people
themselves native people in the early
19th century held the upper hand they
held the balance of power across most of
the North American continent so the
question of the coming decades in the
coming Generations would be you know who
would claim that and who would control
that land
Jefferson hoped that white American
farmers and settlers would sort of
gradually spread across the American
West and turn the United States into
this Utopia of small folding farmers
the Empire of Liberty never really
existed at least in the ways that Thomas
Jefferson hoped that it would
in fact it very quickly became an Empire
of slavery after the purchase of
Louisiana in 1804.
[Music]
the involuntary migration of people's
dwarfs the voluntary Colonial migration
[Music]
the number of free European migrants is
dwarfed by the number of African peoples
coming as enslaved people in part
because their labor is so essential to
the process of colonization and also
because the mortality rates of enslaved
African peoples is so high that you need
to bring so many many many millions more
over
[Music]
slaves in the early 19th century before
the Louisiana Purchase were used in a
number of sort of agricultural
Enterprises in the eastern United States
in Virginia they were growing tobacco in
South Carolina they were primarily
growing rice
over time they would be pushed into the
southern interior where the cotton
growing soil was most fertile
slave holding and slave selling is not
just the southern phenomenon
it's not something that we simply can
talk about in terms of the Deep South
it is in fact legal it is considered to
be the engine of development for the
North American society there are people
who are as deeply implicated in the
trade in New England
as they are in the Deep South
across the 341-year period of trade
it's estimated that over 12 million
Africans were shipped to the new world
against their will
2 million people would not survive the
horrific Atlantic Crossing
it
permeated all of American society so
that American society does need to be
understood as a slave Society it's not
just a matter of one series of States
it's not just something that happens
with the Advent of cotton production
foreign
there's been a long sense in European
and euro-american thought
that basically believes if you're not
doing something with a piece of land or
with a river if you're not planting
crops if you're not chopping down trees
for Timber if you're not mining
something
then you're wasting it there were a few
concerns I mean one is that if Americans
didn't lay clay into this land that
another Imperial power would there was
also the concern that if they didn't
seize this land
they wouldn't unlock its Rich potential
they wouldn't be able to gain access to
the resources that it provided they
wouldn't be able to gain access to the
trade that this land provided
it was to be one of President
Jefferson's greatest achievements having
acquired the Louisiana territories for a
mere three cents per acre
this tremendous Wilderness was to be
explored and mapped in order to best
establish an effective way to retain its
control
so Thomas Jefferson and his
contemporaries were hoping that through
settlement and incorporation into the
American political system they could lay
claim to more of this North American
continent than their Imperial rivals
and so he commissioned an Overland
expedition to figure out
what this land was and what sort of
potential it had
[Music]
before the dust settles on his deal with
the French Jefferson pushes Congress to
finance this Grand expedition of
surveillance
the Louisiana Purchase ended at the
Rocky Mountains and the way the
exploration business in Europe work was
you kind of had respect for other
countries and exploring they had done
so by exploring the Oregon Country which
is between the Louisiana Purchase and
the Pacific that might give us a claim
to it
the president's personal secretary
Meriwether Lewis is tasked with
traversing these newly purchased lands
charting whatever might lay West
of the swampy marshes of the Mississippi
River
Lewis actually went to the University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia and spent a
couple of months down there talking to
faculty members
what am I looking for
and so Lewis asked Jefferson to appoint
William Clark to be the co-director of
this Expedition with him
and so they went out and recruited
people to go with them
[Music]
at the time of the Lewis and Clark
expedition Americans weren't really sure
what was out there
they had a fuzzy idea of what the
Contours of the North American continent
looked like but very few of them could
draw a map with any degree of accuracy
in the 18th century in fact most North
American Maps included California as an
island
one of Jefferson's main missions with
this Lewis and Clark Expedition was to
discover a Waterway connecting the
Atlantic Ocean to the Pacific Ocean this
was essentially the dream of Columbus
when he sailed West in 1492 to sail west
and hit the markets of Asia
and Jefferson thought that there could
be a Waterway connecting the two oceans
the person was one of the earliest sort
of transcontinental Pacific Visionaries
in the United States
he had one eye on China and the
potential of the Chinese trade but it
was this dream of trade with China and
the luxury goods that would come to the
US from China that really propelled a
lot of the early American interests in
the American West
[Music]
May 14
1804 Lewis and Clark set off from Camp
Dubois outside of St Louis Missouri
the Lewis and Clark Expedition was a
28-month journey across the American
continent
if you read even excellent textbooks by
highly regarded historians you'll see
different numbers of people
being a part of the Lewis and Clark
expedition
they eventually started out with 51
people including Lewis and Clark
some of them were fur Traders some of
them were just adventurers outdoorsmen
so you need to be a good Hunter you need
to be able to live in the wilderness you
need to be able to hike at long
distances
[Music]
and one of those 51 people was a slave
that William Clark owned named York
was born into slavery
his parents had belonged to William
Clark's Father John
[Music]
New York became a very important part of
the Lewis and Clark expedition
because when they got to Montana
some of the natives up there when they
would go on a hunt
they would allow one person bragging
rights of being the best person on that
hunt and they would take charcoal and
smear it all over their bodies until the
next hunt
[Music]
the Indians in North Dakota and some of
them later on in Montana thought that
York must be the most important person
in this Expedition because he was black
and so there was this famous painting of
them licking their fingers and trying to
see if the black would come off of his
skin but he became a very important
Hunter you had to be very physical to be
successful as a member of the Lewis and
Clark expedition you had to load and
unload boats and you had to carry stuff
over land sometimes or pack it on to
animals
and so it was a slow it was an arduous
really difficult Overland Journey
they rented a keel boat in St Louis
and the Missouri River
flows into St Louis from the West
so they had to go up the Missouri river
which is against the flow
and so they had big heavy ropes that
they tied to the Keel boat and these men
would walk along the bank pulling that
Keel boat loaded with all these supplies
up the Missouri River
it was a tough summer
too tough for many of the men
plagued by an endless heat and swarms of
insects forever battling against
powerful River Kerns members of the
expedition began to quit
[Music]
when they got to the winter of 1804 one
man had died along the way
and he died of a burst appendix
and so they were down to 50.
with one dying and 16 dropping out
they're down to 34.
and then they pick up three one of these
guys was a French fur trapper named
Charbonneau
but Charbonneau was married to a native
woman named Sacagawea
and of course this story has been told a
thousand times
sacaged away as personal Journey
actually began as a slave
she was captured as a child and then
sold to a French Trader
she was still a teenager and she had a
little baby boy
[Music]
Charbonneau was in his early 30s
Sacagawea was in her late teens and the
little baby was named John Baptiste
John the Baptist
18 arduous months into their Trek
supplies were running low
exhaustion and sickness
slowly taking grip
but Lewis and Clark's diminished team
trekked on
when some of their boats tip and they
begin losing journals and scientific
equipment and materials and the men
Panic at Chicago who has her baby with
her who is calm cool and collected and
is credited with grabbing some of the
most important scientific instruments
and some of the core's journals and
saving them from destruction and she's
doing this while tending her baby you
know at night while the men are around
regaling themselves with stories of the
day she is nursing her child she's
tending to her child tending to her
husband Charbonneau and of course
engaging in diplomatic relations on
behalf of the corps with indigenous
communities they're coming in contact
with
[Music]
when they got to eastern Montana they
saw some natives up ahead
on horseback
every time they ran into natives they
were nervous
they brought some fur trade items with
them coffee tobacco cloth items
and they were always afraid they might
be slaughtered
by an Indian group that didn't
appreciate them being there
and they always approached them slowly
make sure that they're not going to be
attacked
[Music]
when they got closer to these men that
they saw riding these horses
they saw that one of them was
Sacagawea's brother
[Music]
now that's a very pivotal moment in time
because she could have told said Lewis
and Clark are you know bad men and
everything and that would have been the
death of the entire crew right there she
had this reunion with her brother she'd
also had a reunion with the rest of her
family
and of course she got the grandbaby
but she talked them into
selling some horses to Lewis and Clark
western Indians didn't like give up
their horses
but she was able to get them just
because they wanted to help her out
and so she kind of had a very special
role in the Lewis and Clark expedition
there's more statues of Sacagawea than
any other American woman in history
thank you
Lewis and Clark discovered over a
hundred species of plants over a hundred
species of animals Lewis and Clark both
kept a diary a kind of a journal three
others so there were five journals that
were kept and recorded and Thomas
Jefferson wanted everything he wanted
drawings of animals and plants and
rivers and Maps because he wanted to
find out what was there through all of
the recordings and and they did do that
they sat down in studiously did all that
during all kinds of weather
in November 1805 they finally caught
sight of the Pacific coast and the mouth
of the Columbia River
to commemorate this groundbreaking
nation-building achievement
and to Mark the United States
indisputable occupation of the land
an exhausted clerk carves his name into
the dry bark of a nearby tree
[Music]
a group camp nearby until the Winter's
eyes began to thaw before making the
perilous journey home in the spring
they made it all the way to the Pacific
coast and then back again along more or
less the same route
so nobody died nobody drowned in a river
nobody fell off a cliff nobody got sick
and died except that one guy with the
burst appendix and to me that's one of
the great stories of it that they spent
28 months in the wilderness
and pretty much everything they wanted
to accomplish they did Clark became very
rich in the fur trade and then became
the territorial governor of Missouri for
several years
Louis however was drowning in debt
his life ended in the early hours of
October 11 1809.
on a Dusty floor
of a rural Inn
as he bled out from gunshot wounds to
his head and gut
had he taken his own life
or was he murdered
the debate continues to this day
five years after his death the findings
from the Lewis and Clark expedition were
finally published
I know the story is that because York
was such an important person in this
Expedition that Clark freed him
to pay him back
and that never happened Clark was from a
Virginia Slave holding family and he
kept him
for years after he's still a slave for
several years after the Lewis and Clark
expedition ended
the Lewis and Clark expedition sort of
locked the American West in the American
imagination it convinced a lot of white
Americans in the early 19th century that
the Pacific coast and this mostly
unexplored region of the West was
something that would one day really
claimed by the United States they
believed that the Lewis and Clark
expedition sort of blazed the trail
there's this misconception I think that
the American West is this battle
between white European Invaders and
Native people but really it's a lot more
fine-grained than that when native
people first began encountering white
Americans they had no reason to believe
the United States was going to be this
immense power that would eventually lay
claim to the continent you know their
first contact with the United States was
generally a few scruffy Traders so they
wanted access to the guns that these
Traders provided primarily in their
conflicts with other indigenous people
because to them other indigenous people
presented a greater threat
[Music]
the success of the Lewis and Clark
expedition had expanded America's
Horizons
the United States was poised to press
further into the continent and to assert
total control over its growing Terrain
[Music]
they were not to know it yet but the
native population of America a diverse
indigenous people
who had thrived on this continent for
millennia
we're about to face a powerful challenge
to their freedom
and their future this was their land it
had always been their land but the
battle for the American frontier
was entering a deadly new phase
they would face disease war and a
belligerent Frontiersman as
commander-in-chief whose genocidal
master plan would forcibly remove native
tribes from their land
thirst for more control would drive
white settlers further west bringing
with them slavery and violence and a
dream of manifest destiny
change was coming
[Music]